yeah this is a passion project I get to
do you a passion review why because
entourage the movies coming up this
Friday some of you may or may not know
entourage was actually a series on HBO
you didn't know that I'm surprised and
it probably means you weren't looking
forward to the movie but now I'm gonna
talk about the series which means now
you can look forward to the movie life
it works
[Music]
entourage the series so entourage was a
series on HBO that went for about two
seasons to long doesn't mean it wasn't
great though it follows Vinnie chase
who's his actor just one of those
one-in-a-million shots he became a big
star actually starts out when he's kind
of a rising star but ultimately it
concentrates on his group of friends his
entourage the internet's bigger now we
have social media so we're all kind of
interconnected with everything but at
the time this was our look into
Hollywood this point you right there on
Sunset Boulevard but you in the meeting
rooms you felt like you were part of
this entourage and your best friends
like this huge movie star you feel like
you were there in Hollywood
among the shitstain smoggy a skyline so
first of all what makes this show great
it was the characters every character in
the show was always likable but each
season one character had their season
work it was just it was them
unfortunately for Jerry for our eternal
seasons were kind of like in the last
couple otherwise known as the seasons
that weren't as great as the rest I
remember the moment when Johnny Drama
became great Johnny Drama is Vinnie
chase the big movie stars his older
brother he came out to Hollywood first
he had his TV show but he's kind of a
washed-up burnout now I remember the
moment in season 3 where he decked Seth
Green's friend and I was like Johnny
dramas amazing then you watch the show
again and you're like no he was always
amazing I just didn't see it every
character in this show resonates with a
different part of you the best of which
isn't even part of his group of friends
is his agent Ari Gold played by Jeremy
Piven this guy is the best always even
in the seasons that you don't like so
much
Ari Gold is always great you can
actually YouTube ari Gold's best moments
or something like that there's a zillion
and a half videos of that out there
but ultimately it's best to watch it in
the show so the stress of the situation
makes his reaction just funnier I would
I loved about the show is the actors who
are like guest spots in the show they
played themselves most of the time Seth
Green is in this show and he plays Seth
Green but a douchier version of Seth
Green I love it when actors can do that
they look all right yeah I'll play
myself but I'll play like a shitty or
version of myself and he just
has fun doing it I love it when an actor
can kind of laugh at himself like that
the first thing I ever heard about
entourage I heard about it when it was
in season 2 which i think is probably my
favorite season I heard it was a show
about James Cameron is going to do an
Aquaman movie and these guys want to be
in it that's what I knew about it that's
ultimately what season 2 is James
Cameron is going to do
Aquaman and Vinnie chase wants to be the
star of Aquaman I watched it and then I
watched the rest of the show as it came
out and I've watched I've watched the
show in its entirety probably four or
five times but it's not perfect
ultimately the show started to make
mistakes first of all they try to
integrate this one character named Dom
in season three wasn't working for me or
any of my friends ever it was a perfect
crowd before you had your crew you know
him you loved them you'll like what we
have together I say we because I'm
vicariously projecting myself into the
show which the show wants you to do but
it just makes me codependent as and
I know that don't care either so Dom
comes in and he's a total douche bag
knucklehead it just starts to take over
everyone and he's just ultimately trying
to overpower everyone he's trying to
force his way into the friendship and
you're like if you went about it a
different way I'd probably roll with it
but you didn't so I want you gone and
they ride him out of the show very
quickly he shows up in a couple of later
seasons but ultimately you're done you
don't have to worry about it later on in
the show they do try to integrate a new
guy into the group but they do it in a
much smarter way they do it because he
and Eric Vinnie chases best friends
their goals align and so they kind of
work together and then they really okay
yeah we can all kind of be friends now
they don't try to shove it down your
throat in a way that's very intrusive
but you just want them to stop and the
last couple seasons I've already bitched
about it in this video but I'll tell you
why the thing I love about entourage is
it goes through this actress phase him
rising him having his blockbuster him
doing his indie movie him falling from
grace and in that you're gonna see a lot
of phases of an actor's life including
the drug addiction that's right the fun
entourage romp that we're having in
Hollywood became the downward spiral
depression of death that is the drug
addiction season where his girlfriend is
sasha grey played by sasha grey that's
right that'd be the pornstar sasha grey
who has zero personality whatsoever this
is sasha grey being really excited this
is sasha grey really shocked there's not
a in or next to her no energy
whatsoever then that wraps up the last
season hits Vinnie Chase is doing this
thing again but ultimately it doesn't
feel the same because everyone's kind of
moved on at different phases of their
lives which I get and I want to see that
I want to see the characters evolve
that's not the problem the problem is
the phase in which they start to really
do that was the season you don't want to
remember so now you're in the final
phase which is the last season of the
show and it's shorter
the rest of the seasons is this really
rush romance he has with this girl he
gets married to Alice even that's the
end it's really not a spoiler this
sounds like I just ruined the show for
you I really did not because if you're
gonna follow my advice you're gonna
watch it through season six and then
you're gonna stop I mean is Alice Eve
even in the movie are they married and
like is she just gone now am I to
believe the last season mattered at all
I was really surprised of marathoning
this show the last time the last couple
seasons the drug addiction season and
the last season it wasn't as annoying
when you can just marathon the whole
thing waiting week to week that's the
town you're like ah another episode that
didn't have the energy that I'm used to
all right let's wait for next week Oh
rinse and repeat guys the last two
seasons for me aside in the end
Entourage is a great show with great
characters great energy it's relatable
it's funny it's really fast if you liked
all that you'll probably watch
entourage the series if you haven't yet
I am thoroughly surprised and I am
thrilled that I get to bring that to you
if you don't like it if you don't like a
group of dudes and their whole bromance
together and they're in Hollywood living
it up trying to get chicks you probably
won't like the show and now if you're
interested you've never seen it you're
now challenged to catch up on the show
before the movie comes out it's gonna be
hard to do that's a lot of hours but hey
who wants the easy road right so
entourage this series on HBO have you
seen it what did you think about it ever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]